Let's see what all
this looks like in SWF.
To begin, you'll want to
download the starter project for
the ImageRequest app.
A download link's posted
in the instructor notes.
I've downloaded the project already,
so let's run it and see what we have.
The interface is extremely simple.
There's just a single
label in the center and
it says that an image will
load over this label.
If we stop the app and go to
the Main.storyboard, we can see there's
actually an image view too, but
it currently doesn't have an image.
It'll be our job to get
an image from the Internet and
display it within this image view.
Now, let's open
the ViewController.swiftfall.
We're going to be doing all our
networking code right within its
viewDidLoad method.
The first class I want to
introduce you to is NSURL.
As you might have guessed,
this class let's us represent a URL.
I'll create an instance
of it called imageURL and
initialize it using a URL string
that I copied beforehand.
This is a URL for
a cat image that I like.
Feel free to use your own URL,
but make sure that it's HTTPS.
We haven't talked about HTTPS yet, but
we'll see why it's important
later in this lesson.
Now that we have a URL,
the next step is making a request.
The class that we'll use for
this is called NSURLSession.
NSURLSession is a class that can
manage network request on our behalf.
We can create our own NSURLSessions
with custom settings or we
can use the shared NSURLSession, which
comes preloaded with default settings.
The shared NSURLSession is
what is known as a singleton.
If you've never heard
of a singleton before,
it's a special kind of object that
can only be instantiated once.
So if I use the shared
NSURLSession in this SWF file and
then in another file I use
the shared NSURLSession,
I'm actually still referring to
the same object in both files,
because it's a singleton and
there can only ever be one.
The use of singletons is common
when it makes sense to only have
one instance of an object.
Now this distinctions may not be
incredibly important to you now, but
I wanted you to know what the term
meant in case you see it again.
Anyways, we don't need to
make custom NSURLSessions, so
we'll just use the shared
NSURLSession for now.
If you are interested in creating
your own custom NSURLSessions,
then you can look at the NSURLSession
configuration class.
It allows you to change things like
the amount you're willing to wait for
a network request before cancelling it.